so I'd like to welcome our presenters
today so our first presenter today is
dr. ray Leavitt so dr. Bray lemon is the
academic director of the Sanford idea to
market program he is the Kumagai
professor of civil environmental
engineering emeritus and the founder and
director of the global project center
GPC here at Stanford University so dr.
Lovitz current research conducted
through GPC as aimed at developing new
financing governance and organizational
approaches to enhance the long term
financial environmental and social
sustainability of these critically
needed but institutionally challenging
projects in recognition of his work he
was appointed by Governor Schwarzenegger
as a commissioner of the California
public infrastructure advisory
commission PIAA C in 2008 and served as
commissioner of PIAA C from 2008 to 2013
before joining Stanford in 1980 dr.
Lebon served on the MIT civil
engineering faculty he also served as a
consultant to many Fortune 500 and
global companies and the design of
project matrix organization structures
and work processes currently he teaches
classes of organizational design and
entrepreneurship for global project and
matrix organizations dr. Lovett founded
and served as academic director of the
Stanford advanced project management
professional certificate program
awarding more than 6,000 certificates to
mid-career professionals in a wide
variety of industry sectors since its
inception in 1999 he was elected a
distinguished member of the American
Society of Civil Engineers and served as
chair of Stanford's Faculty Senate from
2012 to 2013
sir second presenter today is Professor
Pedro ma Korean Pedram is driven by
reimagining how digital technologies
will help address the challenges of
global urbanization he is an adjunct
professor at Stanford University and
also a lecturer at the Haas School of
Business at UC Berkeley where he teaches
and advises entrepreneurs and global
1000 companies alike on the topics of
entrepreneurship business model
disruption and technology innovation
strategy he was previously a principal
at Mayfield one of Silicon Valley's most
story to venture capital firms which he
was part of the investment he
with over 3.5 billion dollars in assets
under management
pedram is a founding partner of the
ratio academy new line ventures and an
entrepreneur and residents at General
Electric and as various roles he focuses
on accelerating the development of new
venture efforts seeking out
entrepreneurs who are equally passionate
about the applications of machine
intelligence connected systems via
analytics and the Internet of Things he
serves as a mentor or advisor to a
number of startups innovation incubators
including the Texas Medical Center
Innovation Center and at M&A and
innovation labs and serves on the
advisory board of Phillips 66 he was a
seat his PhD in engineering from
Stanford University and has had a brief
an exciting stint in the commodities
trading group at Credit Suisse and with
that said I would love to turn it over
to Ray and Pedram and continue with our
presentation today so welcome everybody
thank you for joining this webinar it's
a privilege to be able to share with you
some of the ideas that we cover both in
academic courses and in online courses
through SCPD on the special innovation
challenges for large businesses as I'm
sure many of you are where Stanford is
considered a hub of innovation and
startups faculty students staff members
and others are all launching businesses
and some of the students are doing it
before they even graduate and dropping
out and so there's a lot been written
and said about the challenges of
launching innovative startups a lot of
that is true whether you do it as a two
or three person company working out of a
garage somewhere or whether you do it
inside a company but there are special
challenges when launching innovations
inside big businesses Pedram you might
like to yeah absolutely so one of the
things that rave hi ray and I have had
the privilege of doing is it's actually
teaching this notion of entrepreneurship
and innovative thinking not only to
startups and startup organizations but
also very large companies in the fortune
1000 really across all six continents at
this point and virtually across every
single sector from construction into
retail all the way through to medical
devices and healthcare services and
everything in between and most of the
challenges are fundamentally the same
and what we would like to do today is
talk about some of those barriers right
now that we see and some mechanisms that
you can think about to actually start
adjusting those and actually bring some
innovations to market so many of you may
have been aware of or may have actually
read a book called the innovators
dilemma by play Kristensen who actually
just passed away this last week he was a
Harvard professor and studied a number
of industries and talked about why it
was so difficult for big companies to be
able to commercialize technology that
they themselves had developed and so one
of the challenges is that innovative
technologies that start out
underperforming traditional lines of
business can actually raise their
performance for price much faster than
legacy products which tend to be
incremental now he focuses on disk
drives you can think about solid-state
drives
play also talked about steel mini mills
and so disrupt disruptive innovation are
often called submarine innovation it
comes up from under your existing
clients and under the performance
requirements that they expect and your
marketing people don't become aware of
it because they're not talking to these
kinds of customers until the performance
of the disruptive innovation actually
exceeds the performance of the legacy
application and basically at that point
you're toast and the second thing is
that inside big companies existing
business line managers will often oppose
and and almost always kill these
internal disruptive innovations if they
challenge existing business lines and
the whole point of disruption is to
displace existing business lines and so
you could ask the question of why codec
which invented the digital camera never
succeeded in making a business out of it
you could ask why Xerox that invented
personal computers sold it to Apple for
10% of the original stock and then
disposed of that stock almost
immediately and and this is something
we'll talk about more as we get into the
webinar and how to deal with it so again
that's the book by clay Christensen and
this is the diagram of the same idea so
you've got a sort of a performance
trajectory of the existing legacy
product and then you've got somebody
lower down again this submarine
innovation that's creeping up on you
from underneath and you don't see it
coming because the managers of the
existing business mind so I'm not
talking to the customers who originally
or using the product that has lower
performance that that is not even on
their radar screen so this is very well
understood I think by people in in
business at this point the other issue
this zone to win book by Jeffery more
addresses and that is the fact that
existing business lines will be
challenged by these innovations that
could even if they don't disrupt the
existing business lines they take
resources away from them marketing and
sales resources engineering resources
even top management's attention and the
managers of your existing profitable
business lines are usually senior execs
with a lot of corporate clout and so
Jeff Moore argues and we believe is that
this is a very valid concern for big
companies and so how do you protect
yourself so there really again just to
praise this first of all if you're a
public company you've got shareholder
expectations about what should be your
growth rate of your stock value or what
should be the dividends if you're a very
mature company so you have a certain
capacity for strategic innovation but
the expectations of shareholders for
continuing equity growth and continuing
steady or increasing dividend payments
will take away some of that capacity for
you and then you've got these internal
resource conflicts with existing
business lines that are reluctant to
give up engineering sales marketing and
other resources and then you've got
summary and innovations challenging you
from below and so it's not surprising
that big organizations are often not
able to innovate very successfully so
we're going to talk now
about Geoffrey mores ideas about zone
management and will perhaps embellish
them a little bit with some of our own
thoughts on ways you can make that an
even more powerful framework so Jeff
reamer talks about four zones that have
different time horizons in the top right
hand corner you've got horizon one your
current fiscal year these are your
existing profit lines that are
contributing to earnings typically
subject to annual reviews people are
incentivized based on annual market
share growth profit growth etc and they
get the support of what he calls the
productivity zone so zone money costs
the performance zone this is your
organization's ongoing performance the
productivity zone on various staff
groups that provides support to your
horizon one performance product lines so
the legal the logistics the sales the
marketing the accounting it said all the
existing staff groups in the
organization are contributing often in a
matrix kind of a strut on the left hand
side you've got two disruptive
innovation things that corporations try
to do so they'll do it through internal
corporate venture funds or they'll just
do it by having individual groups
protected from the organization's
skunkworks Tiger teams different names
for them put them in a new office give
them all the perks that startups love to
have you know video games etc etc lunch
trucks coming with with different food
on different days this is a much longer
horizon kind of activity three to five
years and what you're doing here is
you're exploring opportunities for
technical innovation and what tends to
happen is if you don't fence this off
and protected it tends to become a
resource for your existing product lines
to just tweak their existing features so
at Microsoft the Rd organization had
devolved into adding features to Word
and PowerPoint and so on at the time
Mike Steve came in and helped generate
the outside in an innovation plan that
launched the is your product line and
then when you have one of these
innovations that
is going to be launched as a product you
move the one that you've picked up into
this transformation zone and then you
have to pile resources onto it and what
happens is this group is continuously
supporting horizon-1
and as you launch something into that
transformation zone it takes away
resources from the existing business
lines and diverts them to the activity
that's being scaled to become a new
business line so penny would you like to
comment on some of this at this point
yeah so so fundamentally the way to
think about this is is this is sort of
an archetype for how to think about
structuring your an organization such
that it can actually begin to innovate
it's not necessarily saying that this is
how organizations currently do it but
this is basically providing a framework
to think about how it becomes more
efficient to do that and the way that I
often describe this framework and we've
had the pleasure of working with
Geoffrey closely on sort of thinking
through this and inter observing how
he's come up with this actual structure
as well is to think about two sides of
the business the left side on the right
side of the business the right side of
the business is fundamentally around
what are you doing today to think about
your core business your core product
lines and this is the revenue generating
side of the business this is basically
what the shareholders are looking at is
what your customers are interacting with
this is basically for business as its
defined the left side of the
organization is effectively where all
the disruptive innovation needs to
happen and one of the the beauties of
thinking about this framework is
actually thinking about the sort of a
semipermeable membrane if you will that
separates these two halves of the
organization where you can actually
protect things that are that you're
doing that are disruptive in nature from
the business as usual because one of the
fundamental nature's of all these things
is that the financing and the funding
and all the resources that are required
to support the left side of the
organization are effectively
underwritten by the right side of the
organization so what you'll end up
having in a situation like this is if
you don't have this protective structure
and you don't have these you know
quarantine zones if you will that
actually are protecting some of these
disruptive innovations you will end up
with the people
that are actually driving the core
business basically saying well since
we're paying for it you should do
exactly what we're telling you to do
exactly where Bray was mentioning right
now so if you actually have the core
business defining what the innovations
are that you need to be working on
because of the fact that they're
underwriting all of the efforts then you
end up with basically having incremental
innovations that support nothing more
than the core unit so to think about
this is really to think about how can
you start to create frames within the
organization that can actually create
protective structures around which you
can start to think about innovation and
innovation oriented programs and a
select few of those are going to be able
to actually expand to actually become
what he became what Geoffrey Moore
describes to be things that are actually
going to be transformative to the
business and the definition of
transformation here as we're talking
about 10% of them or more of top-line
revenues of the business so it doesn't
become strands transformative until it
has sufficient scale to be meaningful to
the overarching organization and he goes
into detail about thinking about how do
you actually select those those few
processes and those few projects that
are actually going to go into the
transformation zone but this is
effectively just to think about a
high-level architect and we'll talk
about some of the methodologies and how
to actually start putting some of these
programs in place now so we'll go in
more detail especially into the
left-hand side of the organization how
you protected from the right-hand side
how you fund it in a different way how
you direct the kinds of things it does
in a different way to protect it again
from becoming just tweaking your
existing product lines because if you do
that
these Submarine innovations will come in
and hit you out of the blue from under
the water just jaws style and so how do
you do this we'll talk about this now in
a little more detail
so if you think about some of the kinds
of metrics that are used you know the
existing performance zone is looking at
booking this revenue contribution
margins market share what fraction of
the customers account you're getting or
the wallet share the productivity zone
is really the Six Sigma you know stable
reliable predictable support for the
existing business lines the number for
the incubation zone this is where you're
really looking at identifying new
technologies new business models new
solutions that could could be
drastically better than your existing
product lines and you can think about
them in two ways and Jeff Moe talks
about this also some of them are
defending your existing business lines
against outside disruption so they might
need you to take an existing product
line and put it in the cloud because you
know salesforce.com has cloud software
and you don't and it might be adding
features that other customers have that
are turning out to be disruptive because
they drastically improve the value to
the customer of the particular solution
so you're both playing defense and
offense with the things that you
launched in this incubation zone and
we'll talk about this later on but this
is just one way that if you go on
offense and defense which is things you
develop yourself you can also partner
with others you can acquire outside
companies and and of course all of those
are things big corporations do so in the
incubation zone what you're looking at
is really a whole different way of
thinking about what's important you need
to have representation from your CEO and
you need to have very strong support
from the very highest levels of the
organization again to protect you from
this idea that the existing business
lines will take your resources and
squash you if they feel threatened by
you and so you've got to have something
like a venture capital model there where
you have an investment committee which
is comprised of possibly some outside
people that understand the technology
ecosystem better than your
the organization could because they're
closer to it people who are venture
capitalists still people who are very
well connected in various technologies
but then you also need some strategic
representation and if you want to just
do random innovation in which case you
just look like a conventional venture
capitalist and in the transformation
zone what you've got to do is bring in a
manager who knows how to scale a
business to take this idea that's come
out of your incubation zone that looks
like it has potential Jeff Moore argues
you really have to do just one of these
at a time because of the way she level
whelmed the organization you certainly
can't do four or five at a time even in
a big company perhaps especially in a
big company and we can look a little
further now at how you do this
incubation zone so I don't you pitch in
here Pedram sure so one of the biggest
things that I think a lot of people have
a tough time grappling and and this is
especially true in large organizations
is they'll come up with with a new idea
or they'll come up with some form of a
new technology and the the automatic
assumption is that the technology is
effectively going to become consumable
by the market almost immediately because
it has some some very specific technical
merit to it and one of the challenges
were thinking about that is the fact
that technology is not something that
people actually consume people consume
products and solutions and services and
so part of the notion of actually
thinking about how do you think about
the structure of the incubation zone is
to also think about how do you then take
some of those nascent ideas that are
either technologically oriented or
they're you know native solutions that
really aren't quite productized and
actually give them the mechanisms and in
the structure by which you can actually
start to get some market feedback and
this is part of the core of thinking
like for example as what Ray was
mentioning like a venture capitalist
because as a venture capitalist our role
is to sit there and not just look at a
core technology and say this is a great
technology our role is to actually look
at the complete solution and understand
how that technology addresses a problem
who exactly it is that problem is being
addressed so what are the market
segments that's being going after what
are the cost structures you know
not only developing the product but also
thinking about the cost structures of
actually getting this into the market
how much you're gonna get paid for it in
the long run what strategic value is
this going to add how much value is this
going to create as a whole so there's a
whole slew of questions that actually
get overlaid on top of all of these
nascent technological ideas and concepts
that also then need to be flushed out
and this I think by and large is is
where a lot of companies struggle where
they understand exactly how to bring a
technology to a certain point of
maturity but they can never really turn
the wheel of figuring out how to take
that technology and convert it into a
product and this is effectively the same
thing that we talk about when we start
to say that a corporation should also be
starting to think about I'm having the
the internal skills and the internal
functions to be able to actually take
those products and take those ideas and
actually put them on a pathway towards
becoming product eyes and taking them
into market as well and in particular
your existing sales organization might
not have any idea how to sell a new
disruptive product and so you've got to
come up with what ifs you'll go to
market strategy who are the beachhead
customers how do you expand to a larger
group of customers what is the cost of
sales if it's a very innovative product
you have to educate the market you need
a big marketing and PR budget as well as
a sales budget and so learning how to
think like that is probably what for
Xerox to give away the personal
computing business they had invented
bitmap screens they didn't truly invent
the into Ethernet not any politician who
claims to have done that they so they
had networked bitmapped many computers
they weren't quite personal computers
but they were on the way to becoming
personal computers with mice that they
brought in from SSRI and improved on
they had the whole personal computer
ecosystem in Xerox Palo Alto Research
Center about 500 yards from where Pedram
and I are sitting and they never
commercialized that why because they
were a copier company they leased
copiers to big companies that was their
business model they leased them and
serviced them
you paid by the page they actually had
an interesting version of current
subscription models but they only knew
how to sell or how to least rather
copiers too big
businesses like Stanford University we
used at least Xerox copier and printer
here and so they couldn't imagine how
you would sell these personal computers
and they said we're a copier company
this is not what we do and they
literally gave it away to Steve Jobs and
Steve Wozniak for almost nothing what
one one one great sort of example
literally from a conversation I was
having yesterday it's actually thinking
about for example a sector like consumer
packaged goods so companies like
Unilever Johnson Johnson Procter and
Gamble very very successful companies
brilliant products across the entire
spectrum of what consumers are are
actually I'm consuming on a daily basis
but if you actually think about their
business model it's not direct to
consumer they advertise direct to the
consumer but the consumer never actually
interacts with most of their products so
one of the more interesting recent
acquisitions that we've seen by for
example by Unilever is the acquisition
of a company like Dollar Shave Club
whereby that provides them the direct
access and the direct channel to a
different business model so it's really
interesting to think about even a
consumer packaged goods company needing
to think about how do you innovate on
reaching those customers in
fundamentally different ways because
that's not an innate skill or an
internal skill that the traditional CPG
companies actually have how do you do
digital marketing having new digital
online sales
how do you do subscription sales of a
you know of a disposable product and so
all of these actually have to do we're
thinking about the fact that sometimes
these innovations are on the product
sometimes there are actually around the
business model and this is effectively
all the things we want you know folks to
start thinking about to say all of this
needs to be modeled experimented with
and really tried out within this
incubation zone constructs and one of
the really important things that Jeff
brings out in the book and we would
reinforce is you don't finance the
incubation zone with annual budgets the
way you do or you don't finance projects
in the incubation zone you might give
this own a budget that they would not
pass that budget on to the projects on a
time frequency what they would do
look at how those products of being
de-risk they would be risk the
technology first of all and then they
would dearest the market by showing that
they can sell it to at least a few
people in if this beachhead or in an
early market segment before you would
even think about transforming it and
pouring all those resources into making
it a large business and so you're not
again you're not funding it on an annual
budget you're funding it based on
milestones with gradually increasing
amounts of money which is exactly what
people in the venture community do and
then when it gets to a certain size 1 or
2 percent you've shown you can sell it
to some people you can understand how
you could sell it to more people then
you pile on the resources and bring in
the manager that's going to crack the
whip and grow this into a big business
and then the CEO has to talk with the
performance own people and get them
behind the new product and if they have
to change their incentives because
they're going to probably lose some of
the support from the productivity zone
which might affect their sales and so
the whole business will will have to go
through what some people call it Jacob
you'll go down before you go up and
everybody's got to be on board
incentivize the CEO has to stay on top
of this and give very very clear support
to this new innovation or it will get
squashed guaranteed there's there's one
nuance and subtlety right that I just
want to make sure that people understand
as you're describing this is that what
we're not saying is that the entire
corporation needs to behave like a
start-up and in fact that's a disaster a
corporation is not structured as a
start-up it's not designed to take those
types of risks and the mentality that
the overarching corporation should think
like a start-up in my opinion from all
the things that I've seen and all the
various companies I've advised is
actually a disaster or actually saying
is that the new products the new ideas
and the things that are going to be
experimented with inside of the
innovation zone those are the things
that need to be treated like a start-up
and so in reality a corporation should
be thinking more like a venture
capitalist in a particular sub segment
of what it's doing
not that the overarching corporation
needs to be on this startup oriented
mentality and basically putting not only
the existing culture but the existing
customer base and the existing product
at risk because it's trying to innovate
at its core and those are the types of
things where we see there's there's
often a lot of cultural issues with
doing that and to be honest with you
that sends a lot of confusing signals
back to the market as well
because now people are saying well
what's wrong with your core product what
why do I you every single you know day
you're trying to innovate on its we
don't really understand what you're
trying to accomplish
now you're actually confusing us by by
issuing new releases so fast we can't
keep up with him and so on especially if
it's not what you do if your company
like Amazon and you're and you're
releasing things multiple times a day
absolutely that's what people expect of
you but if you're not that and you start
to do this then people start to get
confused right so you need to do this in
a very structured way and that type of
thinking needs to be limited to new
innovative projects and programs and at
the same time your incubation zone is
not just a generic venture capital
operation it's got to be linked
strategically to what's happening in the
performance zone and what's happening to
your competition and the performance
zone to the extent you can see it and
this and this we'll talk about shortly
as well as so how do you grow a business
again it's a little different when you
incubate a seed technology from when you
decide you're actually going to grow a
business and you move from you know four
people in a garage to 10 15 20 people
with substantially more capital and
substantially more structure and role
specialization the people that are
selling are probably not the founders
anymore you've got professional
salespeople and so you're going to
you're going to take this little startup
business and you're going to turn it
into a real business probably by
bringing in an executive who knows how
to grow business and that's often quite
difficult for the founders to be given a
Northwest promotion to chief technical
officer but that's often what you need
to do to make that happen
so in the construct of the difference
between the incubation zone and the
transformation zone the way to think
about this really is to say you're not
just trying to incubate new ideas for
the sake of incubating new ideas but
you're not doing this just so that you
can do
Marketing of you know what is it you're
taking care of your stakeholders and
your shareholders saying we're
innovative look at the number of
experiments we're running simultaneously
you're doing this under the guise that
you are actually going to then create
top-line value and and top-line benefits
to the organization and a select few of
the activities of the projects and of
the initiatives within this incubation
zone actually belong and what is defined
to be the transformation zone and those
are the ones where you start to actually
pull resources at a substantial level to
actually try to drive a few of these
things into something that's
fundamentally mirror and and I'm driving
a significant amount of new value to the
organization as a whole
so to start thinking about you know what
are the overarching structures that you
can then use from a more practical
perspective to tie out what we think
about this sort of left side of the
equation we've developed a new framework
and this framework is really just
thinking about how do you think about
all the different innovations that are
happening here ray mentioned Xerox PARC
which is literally just down the street
from us here as being one of the the
forefathers if you will of the the
innovation construct of actually
developing products in a more advanced
R&D archetype that structure really
really worked back when you could
actually put all of the experts in the
world in one room and give them coffee
and tell them to go innovate it doesn't
work in today's environment by and large
where innovation doesn't always come
from the inside of the organization new
ideas new capabilities new technologies
are coming at you from all kinds of
different directions so as a structure
one of the things that we strongly
recommend is to think about how do you
then have the entire scope around the
source of innovations and this is
effectively what our x-axis or the
bottom axis here is you have innovations
that come from the inside of the
organizations you have innovations that
come from outside of the organization
and hopefully you have structures in
place that allow you to blend the two in
between and actually have hybrid
innovations
courses where you're working jointly
with outside organizations so this gives
you the ability to think about all the
different types of sources of where
these new ideas and innovations can come
from now what we've seen a lot and I see
this literally on a daily basis when I
have conversations with with my my
advisory companies is they don't really
have a good definition of how to think
about what is the stage or the phase of
this innovation so what we mean by this
is to say what is the purpose of this
are you trying to peer around the bend
to figure out where the future is going
are you trying to just get a sense of
where is the market getting to are you
trying to discover effectively what the
future potential is some of these ideas
can be or what are the future potential
disruptors can be that's in the
discovery phase where you're casting an
extremely wide net just to try to
extract as much information as you can
for the market then a few of those are
going to go up into over Collington
development phase and this is where you
actually start to interact with the
market so when we think about
traditional on BD what most
organizations are really good at is the
big R right and the D associated with
their core businesses what we're talking
about in terms of the innovation
development phase is how do you think
about launching these new businesses and
new product lines new service lines and
new business models and how do you start
to take some of those things and start
to actually put them into revenues and
then in the parlance of the
transformation zone it really talks
about are we delivering value at scale
to the organization are we delivering
strategic IP are we delivering strategic
revenues growth margins there's a whole
variety of way defensive mechanisms
survival survival in many cases right
it's it's that you know that antibiotic
pill that you needed as an organization
to keep you humming for another ten
years and so this is really what we
start to think about when we start to
say top-line delivery and innovation can
help deliver against each one of these
different stages or phases of innovation
from discovery to development to
delivery of top-line value and if you
put these two constructs together you
end up with effectively a frame that
gives you this
by three matrix and what we've done is
we've tried to map out to the best of
our abilities what are some of the
existing structures and initiatives that
we've seen that fall into each of these
categories the easiest thing to think
about is obviously internal discovery
and that's what we think about when we
think about traditional R&D functions
itself this is really a Jeff Morrison to
an incubation zone it is this is this is
effectively part and parcel of thinking
about the entire left side as we're
talking about that as well now what we
were also seeing which i think is a
really interesting new construct over
the past ten years right and some
companies have actually been doing it
longer still is to think about how do
you bring external ideas into your
organization and these external ideas
can come from for example sponsored
hackathons or research around thinking
about competitions and how do you
actually put some of these questions out
to the market and try to get some
feedback around what it is that you're
trying to solve for or many cases you
may actually either launch your own
accelerator or sponsor an accelerator
where you're seeing a lot of different
early-stage companies and entrepreneurs
come with their own ideas and you can
actually interact with them to kind of
get a sense of how is the next
generation of folks I'm thinking about
what the future is doing now there's
another very easy way to do this that a
lot of corporations have embraced and
that is to join industrial affiliate
programs at universities and Stanford
has a variety of these in semiconductors
in renewable energy in construction
digitization etc and so these are we not
only do you meet with academic
researchers you meet with startups that
are spun out of the university you meet
with competitors of yours who are doing
things that you learn about and you can
talk about in a way that insulates you
from antitrust concerns because you're
working in a university environment you
know you're not meeting in a
smoke-filled room with cigars and so
that that university industry affiliate
program you know with universities that
are strong in areas you're interested in
is a very good way I think to see around
the corners along with the things that
Pedram is mentioned and a platform based
community to me one of the ways to do
that is to become a limited partner in a
venture fund that is
focused on the sector you're interested
in where again you'll see all of the
startups that they're reviewing you'll
see the ones that they choose to invest
in you can learn about the ones they
passed on and you can meet again with
other strategic investors in these in
these venture corporations so the the
venture group that I work with as a
number of strategic partners who I think
in a really interesting look at
technology outside and to just build on
Petra's point for a moment the
statistics on what spent on internal
corporate R&D labs versus what spent
outside show that there's way more money
piling into venture capital than there
is in the sum of all of the corporate
R&D labs not only in the US but in
Europe and in Asia and in other parts of
the world so there's much more happening
outside your organization that's
potentially interesting than what you
could ever do inside and and this really
gets us into that the mechanisms to
think about well first of all do you
have within your organization a culture
of well if it's not invented here then
it must not be good and that sometimes
sort of gives us the sense that well
you're not necessarily trying to
innovate you're just basically trying to
then consume everything on your
innovations and support your innovations
but you're not doing it in the most
efficient way right you're not doing it
in the most honest and truthful way and
and that's effectively what you know the
rate raise examples of the you know the
investment into the five separate funds
or the collaborations within you know
universities these are all mechanisms by
which to actually expand the scope of
where these new ideas are coming from
now we're not gonna have time to talk
about each of these boxes at extreme
length but I just wanted to touch on
just that middle layer where we talked
about skunkworks the studios and the
corporate venture functions all of these
have to do with development and
development is effectively the muscle
that I think a lot of corporations are
lacking right now when it comes to new
ideas that are that are really not just
the adjacent ones or things that they've
been comfortable with in the duration of
their life but it actually talks about
things that are outside of the scope of
their comfort zone and these are the
things that need to get developed and
this is exactly what some of the
programs that we do for example the
ideas market program really tries to
teach people is
as you're thinking about developing
these ideas that you've discovered
whether it's through a you know in
affiliation with the university or
research organization or an idea that's
actually percolate enough from your
research organization or organically
through one of the various other
functions you have inside your company
you now need to actually have
methodologies and mechanisms to take
those to the next level and those are
the best practices and the best
principles that you can think of that
you can then borrow from both the
venture capital and the startup
ecosystem to actually put a structure
and a process and engage that sequence
in place to make sure that you're
efficiently developing some of these
ideas such that one day they'll be able
to deliver the value to the organization
that you're looking for and this is
effectively the new type of thinking
around innovation from corporate
perspective that we think is going to
really revolutionize some companies and
the companies that are getting behind
this development cycle in this
development phase I think are going to
be the ones that are gonna have the most
number of innovations that are truly
going to reach market and that are not
just gonna die on the vine yep you might
like to say a little about what a
venture studio is at a venture studio is
effectively the way to think about that
is if you think about a traditional
spunk Works program for example a
skunkworks program you know a name from
Lockheed in terms of what they were
doing it's an extension of a research
development facility because of the fact
that it's actually designed to deliver a
value and products into the market but
it comes from them so it comes exactly
it comes from inside it's locked down
and it's only really focusing maybe with
one or more clients right and so for
example the sr-71 blackbird is
effectively the structure by which the
skunk works with the structure by which
that blackbird came to market for the US
government they're still farmer exactly
it's another one of these where you're
building production capabilities but in
a very limited profile around something
that is still border line of research
project and basically Apple developed
the Macintosh in a separate building
with a bunch of different people I had
the chance to visit that and it was so
different than any corporate environment
I'd ever seen I couldn't believe it you
know video games ping-pong tables bows
and all for grand pianos in the age
this building right I couldn't see
anybody who is actively working and and
the interesting thing with that is again
those are innovations that you're trying
to manage and bring up internally the
venture studio extends that model by
saying what are the expertise from a
team perspective from an execution
capability perspective from an IEP and
Technology perspective from a capital
resource perspective and potentially
from a channel to market and
distribution perspective that you may
not have internally that you're looking
to partner externally with so it extends
that notion of the skunk first and
saying we know how to do all these
things inside by basically saying well
now that we've identified that we do
have some shortcomings that are limiting
or prohibiting our speed to market we
need to start coming up with
methodologies by which we can actually
have been much more hybrid orientation
towards a support program and that
effectively is a new type of structure
that we're calling a venture studio and
one of the best ways I've seen of doing
that is for a big corporation to pay for
what I'll call non-recurring engineering
done by a start-up to add features that
you need for your business and then you
will get repaid in terms of license
discounts of 2x the amount of money you
put into non-recurring engineering and
you will encourage and allow the startup
to sell that to the world after some
limited time maybe six months or a year
when you effective your beta testing and
forum and I've seen very successful
examples of innovations done that way
through non-recurring engineering
payments to startups you often don't
want to invest in a start-up or take an
ownership position of any kind because
that might limit their exit
opportunities and it also might kill
some of their customers but paying for
non-recurring engineering for features
they want is a great way to fill that
phone in on a product or service line
that you need absolutely so this is you
can imagine as a rich area that we can
talk about for hours but in the interest
of time and to make sure that we
actually get some of your questions
answered we're going to turn it back
over to Mona who's gonna actually guide
us through a short Q&A period as well
great well thank you so much for the
presentation and discussion this is
definitely very interesting we're also
getting a lot of great feedback and
questions from our participants okay so
moving on to the first question you know
we have
attracted audiences from a variety of
different backgrounds and this kind of
stood out to me as something that's very
interesting
so one participant asked how does the 3d
innovation management matrix or a lot of
the frameworks that you've talked about
apply to nonprofit organizations or
teams or you know organizations that are
restrained by funding or kind of donor
requirements you know what is a creative
way out or how do you kind of innovate
in this context when there are so many
restrictions on you know where the
money's coming from and what you can do
with it like I'd love to take that one
briefly I have two daughters who work in
that nonprofit space and it's a very
tough space to work in you have two jobs
on this year an endowed foundation like
the Gates Foundation you have to raise
the money and then you have to do the
work and it's literally two jobs if
you're a small organization but
essentially you're still competing
you're not the valley your offering is
not a sort of financial ROI it's an
environmental return on donations or a
social return on donations and you're
competing with a lot of other nonprofits
that are going after some of the same
net high net worth individuals the same
foundations same family offices and so
you have to do just exactly the same
thing I think that any entrepreneur does
you've got to offer a return on
investment except again it's not a pure
financial return and so I think all of
these ideas apply and you can see
nonprofits get disrupted by other
nonprofits that come up with more
compelling arguments to the high net
worth individuals and the foundations
that support them and you've just got to
keep innovating and you have to show
that you deliver a very high value for
the money they give you you're not
consuming at all on your own salaries
and your own overhead and and you have
to deliver deliver that value in
creative ways in technologies a big part
of the way this is done these days so
just a quick follow up on that so so
interestingly enough women actually and
advisor to to nonprofit organizations
one of the healthcare space and one in
the energy sector and what makes those
EE interesting is that they're also
regulated which makes it even more
complicated to think about a non-profit
also in a regulated if armed but to be
honest with you one of the the most
important things about think about some
of these frameworks is that
you need to treat these as businesses
now you may not be ROI driven from the
perspective of financial returns but you
have to be ROI driven in terms of some
form of metric as Ramos pointing out
that you're trying to accomplish and
achieve and you have to think about how
do you take every single dollar that's
coming in to more efficiently generate
that are alive that you're looking for
and the second half of the answer which
which is sort of very exciting I think
both today and I is is the course that
we teach in the spring quarter which
Moda mentioned we actually lift any
requirement that the entrepreneurial
process that we teach has to be applied
to a start-up that raises venture
capital dollars and in fact every year
we end up with our students pitching to
us nonprofit organizations now that
doesn't mean that these are just profit
losing organizations these have to be
sort of businesses that can sustain
themselves on an ongoing basis in some
way shape or form and really having
those operating metrics and that
operating philosophy and that culture of
an organization that continues to drive
the value forward so 100% of everything
that we describe today fits squarely
within the operating paradigm of how
nonprofits should also be thinking about
innovative and by the way some of those
are extremely innovative with technology
using drones to deliver medicines to
remote hospitals etc etc so don't think
that you know all nonprofits are just
sort of hand-wringing environmentalists
or or people worrying about child labor
in some part of the world there's some
really really really high-tech and very
sophisticated nonprofits that are that
operated in small scale or a large scale
reading so our second question kind of
comes down to you know participant image
and so from my personal observation it
seems like the biggest hindrance to
innovation you know within the
organization is really you just power
fights due to office politics know folks
fighting at the mid-level folks fighting
at the high level and a lot of kind of
stuff gets delayed in that process so
two questions related to that so we're
looking back at the innovation
challenges would you say that it is kind
of at its core a people problem and you
and when it comes to you kind of people
problems hindering innovation in the
organization what type of
recommendations do you have as to how to
kind of overcome resolve what I would
argue is when you put a mix of people
into any kind of social setting whether
it's a cocktail party or a business
there are egos at play there are
anxieties at play there are all kinds of
things going on and a lot of that is
random the stuff we're talking about is
non-random politics that is the existing
business line will always oppose
something that threatens their
performance metrics and their careers
and their their their salaries and
bonuses and so you know in terms of
dealing with random politics and we
don't really address that in this course
although we may have our own thoughts on
that we're talking about so the systemic
politics that will exist in
organizations and how you can both
structure and operate around those more
systemic kind of politics that you'll
find everywhere and and it's 100% a
people problem and the way to think
about that is that logos right so your
your company logo your company name
isn't actually delivering anything
necessarily it's the people inside that
organization that are and so as a result
it's also going to be the people that I
grew to be innovating inside of that
organization and so the entire matrix of
an organization and how its structure is
part and parcel of thinking about how
it's actually going to be able to
innovate and develop new products and
services and and to raise point there
are systemic issues as was pointed out
that exists within these notions of that
that are more in line with with things
that are disruptive to the core business
and one of the biggest and most
important things is to the
identification of very very very senior
champions of the organization because
without that support at the topmost
level of the organization these things
will never be able to actually deliver
organizational value right it's always
going to be based on serendipity so one
of the things we always encourage is to
have that top-level alignment with a
senior leadership and then that gives
you the air cover around which you can
then have these more tactical approaches
to thinking about the teams and
everything else and then those
secondary cultural issues of those sub
teams that come to life but at least
from an organizational perspective we
have some ideas and some thoughts around
how do you then create that high level
alignment which is extremely important
and I think there's a different
conversation to be had with the leaders
of organizations about creating a
systemic culture about how we do things
and how we behave in the organization
and that's mostly not about what they
say it's mostly about what they do they
model the kind of behavior that they
would expect others to have and if they
don't they're viewed as inauthentic and
they often don't inspire their employees
and sometimes they end up being being
pushed out almost like a virus is pushed
out by by an antibody and so I think the
addressing the questions of whether
people treat others with respect how do
you treat subordinates how do you treat
racial minorities or ethnic minorities
how do you treat women how do you treat
LGBTQ people all those kinds of things
are modeled by senior people in the
organization and a lot of those kinds of
politics are really more about
organization culture than about the
things we're talking about today and
there are there are courses that that
actually talk about this there are books
about this but I think it's really about
senior leaders creating a culture that
then others will follow and you know if
you're if you're behaving in a way that
shows disrespect for any particular
group or any particular stereotype
you're creating an organization that's
basically not going to function well
because you'll stir up more and more of
this politics that's the curse at the
national level it occurs in a you know
in a start-up that occurs in a big
company so kind of along those lines
right someone asks you know how do you
convince leaders or folks who are in
senior positions to you know support
these newly created kind of
entrepreneurship functions or you know
kind of the technologies that are that
they're exploring stuff instead of just
seeing them upfront as enemies or
intruders or you know someone who's kind
of competitive but in a negative way so
the most difficult thing to do is to
persuade the senior executive of an
organization that's Curren
we perceive to be doing well to change
anything so IBM was basically going out
of business although some people in the
organization didn't act as though that
was happening when they brought in Lou
Gerstner to basically rescue a national
treasure which was IBM they were selling
hardware that had been unique and and
and had no competition but then they
were forced to define the boundary
between the hardware and the software
then you've got plug compatible hardware
from embell from Hitachi from other
people and so Lewis garrison ax came in
and tried to change organizations from
within IBM from being a product company
to being a global service company he is
one of the few leaders that's ever done
that with a big company it took him 10
years and he was an exceptional leader
and an exceptional creator of culture
and if anyone's interested in thinking
how to transform a big organization the
book that he authored who says elephants
can't dance is if some marvelous wiener
it's actually a really fun read to but
that's a talk about how you can change
the culture of an organization if your
organization is struggling which they
began to realize at a certain point the
Board of Directors began to realize that
IBM was struggling and they brought in
somebody who was not an engineer to run
the company IBM had been run by
engineers Watson and successors since
the founding they brought in a guy who
came out of American Express and RJR
nabisco you know consumer products
tobacco cookies American Express credit
cards and a lot of the engineers in the
company were a guest and he'd
successfully turned that company around
but if the company is failing they will
be very open to this and again there's
got to be a leader who is creative and
inspired enough to be able to understand
so if you're in an organization that's
currently doing well and you're trying
to propose something disruptive if
you're going to have a very tough row to
hoe the thing you might be able to do is
to point out to senior executives where
those submarine challenges are coming
from or where outside technologies are
coming that will disrupt them people at
IBM were warned about mobile phones they
were warned about the internet stance
Steve Ballmer said no one will ever buy
these phones
etc and so you know IBM Microsoft rather
was doing very well and they were not
open to these ideas they've got too late
into the internet although they're
recovering now to some degree under new
leadership and they got very late into
mobile phones and through that
completely by buying Nokia and forcing
it to use Windows Mobile so yeah so
still we have a lot of interesting
questions coming in I think we have time
to maybe address just one or two more so
one question is how can you know this
person Vincent mentioned some specific
names I'm gonna try to flare them out
here how can dine essaouira companies as
in like very kind of tech companies with
you know lots of businesses very long
legacy kind of huge assets maintain your
innovative competitive competitiveness
when they carry debt you know such as
pension obligations such as a lot of
kind of just heavy baggage you know
within the organization in general and
these problems are not experienced or
present in some of the newcomers you
know like smaller startups or someone a
new comers an industry like how can you
maintain competitiveness and such under
such a content and you'd like to do it
in a way less extreme and putting your
company into bankruptcy and writing
before your pension and other
obligations as the big auto companies
did it is others have done better maybe
you have some folks yeah so absolutely
so so one of the things to think about
is every initiative every activity that
we've described these needs to get
underwritten by some portion of the
business and and one isn't a such an
important point that this that's being
raised in this question which is how do
you actually finance some of these
different activities and initiatives one
of the one of the biggest things that we
start to think about is how do you start
to actually think about the innovation
in and around the capital structure of
an organization and there's there's a
whole variety of different you know
issues and topics that that raises in
and of itself there's a few extremely
high level responses that I can give
right now it's sort of in the interest
of time one of the ways to think about
that is that you don't necessarily need
to underwrite all of your innovation
activities and if you think about the
matrix structure that we described you
can actually start to push more of your
innovation to be external where it's
being underwritten by either research
organization such as such as
universities it's being underwritten by
you know
time in sweat equity from startups is
being underwritten by external venture
capitalists there's a whole variety of
other mechanisms that actually finance
these types of innovation activities
that you can basically support without
having to underwrite all of them so the
more you think about having more blended
and more external innovation activities
the less of a burden that poses on your
internal organization capital structure
the second thing which is extremely
important is and one of the things that
I hope to sort of see in the near future
is an expansion of the notion of M&A and
actually a description of MA and D and
if we can start calling this more bad
than M&A I think it becomes interesting
what do I mean by this
the DEA's divestitures a lot of these
times these dinosaur organizations as
you're describing actually have really
valuable assets they can either be
monetized by other people in a slightly
better way or just basically somebody
else may want to actually take those off
your hands and this is a brilliant way
for you to start to take advantage of
the fact that if you are adding new
things to your organization new
innovations new product lines
you better have a methodology by which
you're actually shedding some of those
some of that potential dead weight or
things that you know you no longer view
to be valuable to your core you know
strategy going forward but that somebody
else may actually want to actually
acquire off of you and these structures
are a fantastic way of bringing capital
back into the organization to help
finance and under a some of the new
things that you want to support the
biggest mistake that most organizations
make is that they basically are in this
hoarding mentality right well we can't
get rid of this we've had this for 20
years what we also want to add this we
also want to add that well at some point
you're gonna actually have this bloated
inflated structure and you're gonna just
continue to see things that are that are
long in the tooth that are dragging you
down and they're not actually providing
you that free new cash flow to be able
to under I probably some of these new
initiatives so at the highest level
early of the organization above and
beyond just the culture that Ray was
talking about previously you also have
to get that alignment at the highest
level of the organization to start
thinking about what is the capital
structure and the financing mechanisms
that you want to put in place to help
underwrite some of these things it's an
important point and and I hope that
actually
more strategic focus is actually going
to be placed on this versus knee-jerk
reaction is to say well we can't afford
any of this stuff and just a couple very
final comments on that first of all
what's not working in your current
marketplace might work in some other
marketplace in another country for
example where the markets that you're
operating in in in the US or in Europe
might not be as well developed so it
might work in India it might work in
some parts of Africa and so on and there
might be somebody there who wants to
take it off your hands there's a lot of
money in the hands of people that
control resources in those countries and
then the other thing is this is just
basically a different version of
portfolio management portfolio
management is not about what you do
everybody has more good ideas than they
can execute it's about what you don't do
and if you don't decide to not do some
things you will fail any other things
you do well again thank you so much I
know we're past time today but you know
this was such an informative
presentation and you know on behalf of
our audiences I just wanted to thank you
all for your time and sharing this
knowledge with us so if you found
today's presentation helpful we
encourage you to share the recording
with your friends your colleagues or
whoever might find it to be you know of
good use so again thank you all for
spending this hour with us today and
have a great rest of your day